As we saw in the previous code
example, properties can have different types. These are
called property types. For the recipe kind, some
of the property names and types were name,
which was a string. Vegetarian, a boolean indicator.
And the number of servings, an integer. But
these are just a few property types. In
fact, Datastore supports a lot more property types.
And we mean, a lot. The
official documentation on developers.google.com lists around
20 of them. In this class, we're only going to use a small
subset of these. And the ones you can see listed here are some
of the most common properties. Integers.
Floating-point numbers. Strings. Dates and binary data.